he will not want to miss this incredible
conversation
with a legend i call him this century's
carl sagan
and that is no small amount of
praise for dr phil plate who is joining
us today i'm hoping that we are now
live on the into the impossible network
and we are also live co-streaming on
clubhouse for those of you who don't
have video access
or don't have an invitation that would
be so sad uh to not have an invitation
but that's the way the clubhouse
crumbles
and hopefully we can make do with just
our video
extraordinaire and it is such a great
pleasure to welcome
phil plate the bad astronomer himself
where is he got to get him on screen
there he is here i am
there he is joining us all the way from
the wilds of colorado
where he is a gentleman farmer he is a
gentleman astronomer
he is an inspiration to literally
millions around the world
as i say he is this generations carl
sagan here is my finger puppet
phil do you have a finger puppet of carl
sagan
uh no all right i'm gonna have some
puppets and stuff around here but um
yeah i'd have to find them
i will rectify that and if you're really
good i will throw in
a side order of the very first good
astronomer
this is galileo galilei who phil is
intimately connected with oh let's see
what you got there
puppet i have krieger from archer nice
so that's you know that's about the best
i can do i think we
uh you might have did you get that in
san diego at comic-con
uh no that's a long story
uh uh it turns out the the the voice
actor
lucky yates who does krieger is a big
science fan
wow and uh and so he he gave me that so
now i've got a krieger doll and it says
it says rude things when you hit the
button so
well we'll keep this pg-13 at least
um so phil i want to take us back to the
early
uh 21st century 20 years ago when bad
astronomy came out
and uh it's really amazing i have the
audio copy i have the kindle copy i have
the printed copy
and i went back because i was so excited
you accepted this
and i went back and i and i read and
listened to it and i couldn't believe
how much has changed because back then
news anchors didn't know much about
science and were proud of their
lack of knowledge or ignorance about
science there were people that believed
the earth was flat
can you believe that there are people
that aliens are among us even to this
very day
and there were even people back then in
the early part of this millennium
who thought that vaccines were dangerous
it's so glad and so refreshing that
thanks to your book
all that changed and now we have nothing
but science
and uh and the culture of science oh my
god
uh are you disappointed or dismayed at
how little has changed in some ways phil
i see you as
an optimistic pessimist or pessimistic
optimist which is it
yeah um one of the things about
doing this sort of thing and that is
like jumping in both feet
to debunk bad science and i don't i tend
not to use that term quite as much as i
used to
but uh you know you can't debunk
something unless it's bunk
uh and the thing about it is that you
have to go in knowing
that this is going to be probably the
single most frustrating thing you're
ever going to do in your whole life
uh you know you absolutely know going in
that you will make a difference
hopefully i mean you can't know that but
you can hope that you'll make a
difference
but the second part of that is that
you'll have to do it all over again in
five years or less
you'll make a difference with some
people but there there's always new
people coming in this is a pipeline
and so uh you know i can spend
all that time like i did debunking
people who thought the moon landings
were fake
or that you know vaccines have mercury
in them or whatever
uh but what's going to happen is
sometime later
it's just going to be just as strong as
it was you might cause a little dip
and even that that's that's wonderful if
you can do that
but typically it's just that this is an
ongoing thing it's a dynamic process you
can't just say
well you know we debunked that now we're
done let's move on that's
never gonna happen right and and as you
say you know bunk and debunk
uh i never know which one i am bunker
debunk but um but it really made me
think because i had a
kind of um semi-confrontational but but
friendly
good-natured conversation with a man by
the name of steven meyer who is a
proponent
of intelligent design and that has an
awful
you know kind of reputation in
scientific circles uh he's actually a
very sweet gentleman and we had a
friendly debate i'm always very
courteous that's you know i'll have on
people
whatever their viewpoint as long as
they're respectful and not preaching
odious nonsense but
um but he pointed out one thing when we
talk about uh we talk about things like
the multiverse or
string theory and uh and it's always
mentioned that
karl popper mentioned that the criterion
for good science is that it'd be
falsifiable
and he said well you know the earth is
uh
is flat is falsifiable therefore is it
good science you know or is it part of
scientific
investigation and so i said well yes and
no uh
in fact it sure appears that the earth
is flat and i think some of that is
responsible for the perniciousness
persistence of scientific fallacies
but um i first want to before we get to
that if you have a comment on that
falsification is held up as sort of
girdle's incompleteness theorem of
physics
what do you think about this notion that
even though you can falsify something
that still might not make it science
for example astrology or or for the flat
earth
oh i see where you're going um yes uh if
something
is fault okay if something's not
falsifiable
then is it science yes um i can argue
that back and forth
and but if we set that aside and and
take the take the sideways version of
that that you just said
if something is falsifiable is it
science and the answer that is obviously
no
because if i say um i am for
uh you know that's falsifiable yet it's
not science
um that is that is a claim that has no
evidence makes no you know
it it makes predictive uh uh
statements you know if i'm thor then i
can wield mjolnir and i can fly around
and i can summon lightning i can't do
any of that stuff
so that fault's viable but it's not it's
not science
in in a sense you can say it's a
scientific claim
uh because if if i make a claim
that is that has some sort of evidence
for it
uh and that does make some sort of
prediction
then you can say sure that falls in the
framework of science but that doesn't
make it science
uh and so astrology for example is
falsifiable and it has been falsified
to my satisfaction uh many many many
times over so
uh that's not a science now the the the
more straightforward aspect of this
um is that is science you know if if you
make a claim
uh for it to be scientific it has to be
falsifiable
i there i guess there are levels of
detail to that
i don't think that's necessarily true at
first um
if you have an issue in quantum
mechanics
which shows you that for example uh in
one interpretation of quantum mechanics
that every time any decision is made if
you whatever you mean by decision but
anytime
an event can go left or right uh
both things actually happen and you're
just splitting off and creating a new
universe
this is super oversimplified of course
uh this is a whole branch of
of of of thinking in quantum mechanics
and i'm summing it down in one sentence
so please don't
don't you know come with the pictures uh
pitchforks undergraduates should not
bring this up to the exam
this yes exactly but if if that's sort
of your idea and you say you posit well
there's a multiverse
um that is uh you know is that a
scientific claim
well you're trying to explain some
evidence and you don't have a whole lot
of evidence for this you don't really
have a lot of
evidence against it um but that doesn't
mean it's not scientific necessarily
what you have to do is you have to start
thinking about it scientifically and say
well if there is a multiverse is there
something else
that that it might have an effect on
when we look out into the universe
is it does this leave an imprint on on
the universe itself in some way does
this explain
something else uh and any big idea in
science
is going to come along that way i mean
when quantum mechanics itself was first
dreamed up uh there was a problem in
astrophysics where we were trying to
astronomers were looking at the colors
of stars
and the way stars emitted light didn't
make sense
and i want to say it was max planck uh
who came along and said well let's
pretend that light
doesn't behave the way we've always
thought it does let's pretend it's
quantized it comes in these little
packets
and when you do that suddenly that
problem goes away and
uh he just kind of made this up and said
well maybe we're just thinking of this
wrong
einstein did the same thing with
relativity you know he started with a
thought experiment and said
let's see where this goes um and you
know what if you're if your theory
winds up not explaining anything it's
not terribly useful but if it does
uh then it becomes a little bit more
firmly grounded and you can start
testing it
yeah and then there are of course things
that are science fictional
and you start off your book with a
conversation about how lost in space
and all these bad science fiction as you
call it influenced you in a good way and
of course many of my listeners uh
of course know that i am the co-director
of the arthur c
clarke center for human imagination here
at uc san diego
and in this capacity we have you know
paid tribute to
sir arthur's legacy via the quest to
understand the imaginative process that
could couple together
uh fiction and non-fiction science fact
with
with um speculative culture we've had
all sorts of
exposes in that front but i wonder you
know
to what extent has science fiction even
though it's sort of
known to be wrong has it influenced you
and has it made you
you know a better scientist or did it
make you a better scientist um
uh from these considerations of things
of asking the question
could this be possible to have a flat
you know
an orbiting satellite in geosynchronous
orbit uh no that was fanciful is there
anything about science fiction that
inspired you as a scientist
you know it's funny the way you phrase
that has got me thinking now you said
science fiction which is known to be
wrong
and i think well that's an interesting
way to phrase it because
um you can say well if you're writing a
story
you're lying right this didn't happen
it's like well no of course not but i'm
not lying i'm telling you a story
you know there's a there's an agreement
between the writer and the reader
that this is this is made up that it's
not real
so um in that sense and and now that
now i'm thinking about it uh that
actually uh crystallizes some other
thinking i've had
um in in a
in a science fiction story there are
going to be some caveats some some
mcguffin mcguffins as they say in the
business
something you throw in there that the
the the audience
just has to accept warp drive
transporters
uh energy you know directed energy
weapons aliens
you you can make a huge list of these
things and that's that's fine and i'm
okay with that as a matter of fact i
love that because without a lot of those
you can't tell these stories
um it becomes a problem when they're not
internally consistent
uh and so if you if if you posit
something and i'm not gonna you know
worry that if you go faster than light
that's actually a form of time travel in
some sense
you know i'm not going to worry about if
you if you start dealing with all the
relativistic
aspects of your faster than light drive
i don't care about that
um so much in the story but if you use
it one way in in
in one episode and another way in
another episode the contradicts the
first one
i want to know about that you know why
did you do it that way was it just lazy
storytelling
did you just not care you know that
that's the difference between being
fiction and being wrong
uh and so uh uh
in in the i i think i'm hoping to answer
your question along the way here
uh that stories are
important to people i mean that's one of
the one of the first things we did as a
society way back you know hundreds of
thousands of years ago
um maybe not that long ago verbal
language but i mean that stories were
told and we
we we learn from stories we their
morality plays
we learn about uh being human through
these stories
uh we get one of the most important
things for me specifically too
is uh you you see the world through
another person's eyes you get insight
into
the way other people think which i think
is very very important because
when we think we're right and we don't
really have any experience with how
other people deal with reality
uh yeah you're just gonna butt heads
there's never gonna be any real kind of
discussion
that way so all of this is important
and what i found in in for science
fiction for me
uh you know i just love the spaceships i
love the aliens that's just that that
gets me going it just makes me happy
um but there's also a lot of morality
that goes on in
good science fiction like right now the
expanse uh
has a huge amount of morality in it and
there's a
big conflict going on between earth and
mars and and people who live on the
asteroid belt
and the thing is everybody thinks
they're right and the way these
characters are presented
their arguments make sense now whether
they're executing
the morality of these arguments
correctly that's a different story
but everybody's got their own reasons
for doing things and i love that
and it that inspires me uh in in my own
life and in the decisions and the way i
think about life as well
yeah i love the aspect of science
fiction that allows you to
essentially do gdunkin experiments with
speculations about culture
uh because even though the uh you know
kind of tropes to the contrary exist
science is done by human beings and
human beings are subject to all the
foibles
and peccadillos uh even if they are
scientists that all human beings are
sensitive to
and i i think that's uh quite wonderful
when you get to kind of pre-game the
future i call it
when we get to uh explore the nature of
science fiction and and perhaps
understand science fact
uh even better as sir arthur clark uh
certainly impelled us to do
i want to uh just mention to folks that
we are live
with uh we are live with none other than
the bad astronomer
who goes by the moniker the bad
astronomer who is
none other than phil plate who is
joining us from colorado and there i am
with him
uh you can find him on twitter is the
best way to access him
and that is at bad astronomer and he has
a newsletter which i have subscribed to
for a long time and he even has a
youtube channel which is the bad
astronomer i guess bad astronomers taken
uh and we can't always choose our names
people are like you're so haughty you
you have to call yourself dr brian
keating on
on twitter and on uh and on youtube why
are you so naughty about it like are you
trying to be dr jill biden and i say no
i would love to be just brian keating
but the guy wanted like a hundred grand
for those domains so
you know on one hand it's it's
flattering but on the other hand
give it back to me stop squatting on my
domain whoever you are out there
um but you can find him online and he
does such phenomenal work outreach
and definitely subscribe to his
newsletter there's a free version of it
of course you are welcome to do the paid
version
as uh as many many subscribers do
uh yesterday speaking of aliens because
you mentioned it you mentioned the a
word you you brought up the a word um
yesterday you had a
a marvelous tweet now actually i really
want to commend you
on the uh just the throughput the output
that you have
in terms of scientific communication and
we're going to get to that later i'm
going to make a provocative claim phil
that scientists have a moral obligation
to be not as good as you
but we have to do something it's not
enough to not try but we'll get to that
in just a little bit my hectoring
my moral and ethical hectoring of my
fellow scientists but i want to talk
about aliens
because you mentioned aliens um and of
course in the book
you talk a little bit about it as well
and they're replete within
science fiction yesterday you mentioned
omuamua who was
uh which was the subject of a book by a
previous guest of mine
dr avi loeb the former chairman of the
astronomy department at
harvard university a little university
i'm told up in
the northeast and uh avi made the claim
that omumua was
alien technology with a confidence of
greater than 90 percent from his
perspective
yesterday you tweeted out and informed
people
of a rather prosaic explanation for it
and i wonder if you can comment on it
and just as science can be informed
by a science fiction sometimes it can be
hurt by
science fiction in my opinion because
you get this prosthetic forehead and
and you get the alien you know kind of
with the googly eyes and
wanting to probe people and and so forth
uh and i pointed out to avi
just the last thing before i wind up
this meandering question i pointed out
to avi that the majority of alien
sightings are done in america on
planet-wide come from america
and the majority of those come from the
northeast where he is this esteemed
professor so anyway
um can science fiction hurt science
because it'll portray these fanciful
you know narratives of things we don't
really believe to be probable and then
um what do you make of you know kind of
the hype cycle in science from
discovery you know tentative discovery
to like we are being visited by alien
technology what do you make of those two
eating forces
um wow uh okay so the next two hours
i'll be talking about this
um i'll take it you know science fiction
inspires science and that
that is the evidence for that is
overwhelming you can talk to
any number of scientists my age and
younger who say you know they were
inspired by
star trek for example or or battle star
galactica or whatever
science fiction that they watched or
read or consumed in whatever manner
um and and so you can it you can inspire
scientists directly through that you can
also inspire science
you you need some some device to get you
out of trouble in a story and
you whip that thing out and use it and
then some scientist goes
you know there might be something to
that
and that's happened as well you know not
necessarily one-to-one like that but
there has been inspiration from these
shows
or books or whatever uh and
you can you can find history is filled
with things like that
it can hurt science too because if it
represents something incorrectly
uh especially if you're young and you're
consuming this stuff that can be sort of
the way you think about
things uh so you know evolution for
example is always portrayed very poorly
uh in in mass media science fiction you
know you you're always saying
well we're they're they're more advanced
in an evolutionary sense they're
they're uh they're evolving towards
something it's like well evolution
doesn't work that way
you're not more advanced in an
evolutionary sense
you're just more you're better adapted
for a system that that exists around you
uh so you know if a if a
a virus or a cell a bacterium
can can thrive in our environment who's
to say whether they're
more advanced than we are um you have to
define your terms a little bit better so
sure
also the way scientists are portrayed
you go back in the 1950s
and scientists kind of look like me bald
guy beard white
uh generally older with a young
attractive daughter who is also becoming
a scientist who then
becomes uh uh romantically involved with
the hero of the story
that that trope is used over and over
and over again um and that's not true
and so when when you
do surveys and you ask kids you draw
scientists they draw somebody who looks
like me they don't draw a woman they
don't draw
somebody who's not white or anything
like that uh
that's getting a lot better a lot of
movies and tv shows and other types of
mass media are going out of their way
now
to show a more diverse group of
scientists and i love that
um the other part of your question was
um uh
is there a tendency to over hype things
is there a tendency to leap
to a conclusion which is not warranted
by the evidence this is how i'm going to
interpret your question at least
yes uh and that happens all the time and
there's an old critical thinking
uh phrase that says if you hear hoof
beats think horses not zebras
you know unless you're at a at a reserve
some place where there are zebras
but typically you know in america for
example if you hear hoof beats
it's probably horses and you know more
likely than that so
the idea is that look to the mundane
first you don't necessarily jump to the
conclusion
that uh just because an object that
comes from another star is acting in a
way we don't expect
means it's an alien spaceship in fact
let's look at the more mundane
explanations first
look at the evidence and try to figure
out what's going on
in my opinion based on the evidence that
i have seen
dr loeb's conclusion that this is a
spaceship or at least
you know if you want to say it's a
spaceship i would say
the evidence doesn't even come close to
that conclusion
if you say it might be a spaceship
that's different then i'll say well
let's take a look at this and say
you know how would a spaceship behave
why does this thing
make you think it's not natural what is
the evidence that it is natural
and just because you don't have an
explanation for something
doesn't mean it doesn't exist right the
the idea now
is that omua this this object which came
from interstellar space and passed
through the solar system a couple of
years ago
we thought it was an asteroid then it
started acting like a comet but it
doesn't really act like a comet
completely
and there have been a lot of different
ideas that have been positive because it
acted very oddly
and the latest one is that it's a chunk
of nitrogen ice
frozen nitrogen that actually explains
really well a lot of the stuff that
we've seen maybe not everything but
a lot of it and there's even a source
for
chunks of nitrogen ice when solar
systems form so
you know you if you want to posit
something that is
fairly extraordinary alien spaceship you
can't just show me the evidence that
supports your claim you have to show me
why
it's not a nitrogen chunk and i don't
think that has been done yet
interesting yeah and so that would be
the wrong answer but there you go
well that's what i get from rambo the
waiting yeah exactly
and i think it's you know of vital
importance because
to the extent that science is perceived
by the public it's typically
not really only looking at you know
someone like you or me who you know have
certain
uh you know privileged uh abilities and
and past
light light cones so to speak uh but
it's someone you know who does something
very specialized you know with
very specialized equipment you know and
and off access
out of access to a normal person just
the same way like
i wouldn't go down to the hospital to
the radiology department start you know
poking around the mri machine just
because i understand robbie oscillations
or
you know it it's it's specialized right
every time i get an extra i'm like i
wonder what i wonder what uh energy
range this one is
take a look at the black on it start
asking questions yeah yeah can i
remember some of that liquid nitrogen i
gotta test that
theory uh for myself um but uh but yeah
science is perceived as as you know
these special people doing special
things and i think you know some of the
some of the positive things that people
like carl sagan would do
or neil degrasse tyson who's an upcoming
guest by the way so please do make sure
you stretch your little finger and
don't get carpal tunnel syndrome phil
will tell you subscribe not only to my
channel to my twitter to his channel his
twitter
and his newsletter which is uh must read
bad astronomy
news which i look forward to every
monday coming into my inbox fresh and
piping hot
with the latest greatest astronomical
news uh some of which i actually teach
in my
cosmology class i'll i'll bring in some
some cool image and some description
that you
uh very scientifically will link to
other people
uh who do the research and i think
that's what i love about neil degrasse
tyson
i can't wait to tell them in person next
week and by the way there are people
praising you
thanking you for inspiring their love of
astronomy phil so you should know what a
difference you make in the chat room but
all around the world
but let me just say in this second
meandering question
uh people like sagan and people like uh
and people like neil degrasse tyson also
suffer they suffer
because um they're perceived as not real
scientists
you know real scientists stay in the
lane stay in the lab
uh you know don't get out there and and
you know and do the
stuff that you know anybody can do
anybody can do with neil degrasse ty
anyone could do what phil
plate does i mean three ted talks oh
come on anybody can do that
um but they can't really be a real
scientist and so what do you make of the
fact that we're almost punished you know
i was asked once
i actually talked to janet levin who i'm
sure you know um and she told me when
she wrote her first book
it was before she even had a tenure
track position and then
her second book was written she had
tenure and um
and they said um and she asked her
department chair can i get time off
uh to write my next best book which next
book which was a work of fiction
which is phenomenal and uh the
department center said no you can't get
time off
uh but you should feel lucky if we don't
uh penalize you
so it's almost like you know you we as
scientists who write popular works we
almost
get not correct we get the opposite of
credit we get debits so what do you make
of that why is there
a thirst for by the public but almost an
antipathy
from our fellow scientists towards the
work that you so well exemplify
well thank you first of all um
that used to be a bigger problem let me
let me
talking about privilege being born when
i was
uh to have people like carl sagan and
a host of others uh talk about science
in a public
venue and you know carl wasn't the first
uh that that's
a tradition that's gone on for centuries
but he went on mass media he went on a
johnny carson show
a tonight show wrote books wrote for
parade magazine
which is read by you know tens of
millions of people and so
he really went out there and and talked
up not just
science but also the ethics of science
the morality that we have to
uh to to use when we employ science
in our lives uh and and
that was a huge deal and yeah he got uh
he got a lot of grief for it from a lot
of other scientists who were thinking
well you know talking to the masses this
is not what we do
we are scientists we are removed from
the lay people and we we will be in our
ivory tower and dole out
these these bone mulch of wisdom as you
know of reality as as we see fit
and like that's that's garbage in my
opinion um
i i will argue uh the point some people
say all scientists should be out there
talking about their work and i disagree
some are better than others uh you know
i i i watch my friends
who go out and talk about certain things
on tv or on
twitter or whatever and i think wow i
wouldn't phrase it that way and the way
they did it was way better than i would
have thought of
so you know we need we need different
people doing this
uh but we also we need to understand
that
um there are different ways to do this
and different different people who are
who are better at it in some ways than
other
um and i'm always happy to refer to
somebody else
if i think this is a person who can
relay this better than i can
certainly um that has not completely
gone away
it has really been reduced this idea
that we shouldn't communicate science to
the public
we should just be doing science let me
tell you a secret i wasn't that great of
a scientist
um it was okay you know i got my degree
i worked on
uh some some big projects for a while
the hubble and doing some other things
and we published papers and everything
and i did my part
um but it was never going to be you know
big important groundbreaking stuff that
i was working on
um it was important and i was a member
of a team of people doing it
but i wasn't the one you know doing this
this this research and going out and
doing
uh getting all the grants and
doing all that sort of stuff that you
kind of think of when you think of a
scientist
um turns out i'm better at talking about
it so i started doing that
uh you have to find the talents that
people have
and sh and and let's let that bloom
i think so there are going to be
scientists i don't think should be in
front of a camera
and i think there are science
communicators like me who maybe
shouldn't be doing science anymore and
i'm fine with that
yeah that is that's more allowed now i
think i hardly
get any grief from people saying
you know you shouldn't be doing this i
almost never hear that and when i do
it's from people who
don't really understand the importance
of communicating science
um and uh
do i and sometimes i hear people saying
well you're not a scientist anymore and
i'm like i'll cop to that
you know i'm not doing the research
anymore i'm reading as pretty much as
much as any scientist does i read a lot
of papers
um because i have to write about it i
have to understand them to a depth where
i can sit down and write about it and
not
not screw it up completely so i try to
understand the science as much as i can
um but you know not being an active
research scientist anymore yeah sure
that's
that's true but that doesn't mean i
can't still talk about it
and i think we need to appreciate what
everybody's doing in their own way when
we do this sort of thing
absolutely yeah when i think about um
you know science communication and by
the way we've got some
amazing guests in the chat room we've
got christian
uh from launchpad astronomy uh who runs
a huge channel
coming up on a hundred thousand
subscribers and we have a man by the
name of
charles darrow who is married uh to
one of the uh foremost astronomers of
our age
uh professor sarah seeger of uh
shusit's a little technical college
called massachusetts institute of
technology
also in cambridge and we've got a bunch
of people in the chat room which is
wonderful to see
so we're talking again with the bad
astronomer himself
dr phil plate who is a proponent and
exponent
an expert exponent of scientific
communication
charles is saying in the chat room and i
cannot fail to disagree with him less if
you can parse that
uh that science proper communication of
science is as important as the science
itself i interviewed his wife
uh professor sarah seeger and she also
kind of reiterated this stance that
um sometimes you know as as we discussed
the higher you fly the more visible you
are the easier you are to be a target to
shoot down
and i just wonder uh to push back a
little bit on your otherwise excellent
you know sentiment
how do we know uh that scientist isn't a
particular scientist isn't good
at um you know doing public
communication until
she tries it you know i think you know
sarah's very candid with some of the
struggles she had in her career
uh and so forth but uh she's now become
this outstanding scientific communicator
because she worked at it she actually
told me
and this uh by the way this episode will
come out after the episode we're talking
about so it's a little weird
we talked about it in the past but we
talked over almost two weeks ago and she
said she took classes in public speaking
she's taking classes in management and i
always hear my colleagues who will
remain nameless
um you know john lewison no no i won't
say that uh
uh there's no such person uh but uh but
my colleagues say oh i'm not good at
that
and uh it's a lot of work i said oh yeah
yeah i forgot you know
um learning about type 2
superconductivity and type and
pnemectic fluids at uh you know in
condensed matter that was really trivial
i mean you just came out of the womb
knowing that right
you didn't have to work on that at all
did you and uh of course you know they
they
they have to admit that they had to work
at that too uh but what do you make of
this that that
physicists are so resistant or
scientists in general rather are
resistant to it
um to learning how how to do it and
maybe the best way to entree into that
question is how did you learn to do it
you you
are a scientist you came from a
scientific background you're very
conversant
did you did you dedicate some time to
this you know quote unquote craft as
they say
of being a communicator ah yeah
um no yeah i mean yes but no
um uh and and i should say that uh
yeah sarah's great i i was on a panel
with her many years ago
uh and i i just thought she was
wonderful and
um the fact that she she said to herself
i need to
to you know get better at this and i
need to do it in a formal way
is amazing that's fantastic and i know a
lot of people who have done that and
i've thought about it i've actually
considered taking um
improv class because you know if you're
if you're out there on stage
and and there's a lot of talking going
on and you have to come up with
something that makes sense and is funny
and fits in with the overall scheme
that's that's really what
what you and i are doing right here and
you don't want to hog the stage and give
long-winded answers that take 10 minutes
every time somebody asks you a question
not that not that i've been doing that
here um
you know yeah so i think that that's a
great idea
i never actually did anything formal
what happened was
um i just started writing because i felt
like you know i like to write
i can make a point and uh it'll be fun
uh so i i in in that sense i
i did it in a very um um
thought out way where i thought to
myself if i ever want to write a book
and i think i do
which eventually became bad astronomy i
need to
get some notoriety first i need practice
i need to write
that sort of thing and i started writing
articles and publishing them i started
um
doing some free q and a type stuff for
astronomy magazine years ago
somebody would ask a question and i'd
have to write an answer to it
and it had to be kind of brief which you
know that's ridiculously hard for me to
be brief obviously
but i never took a public speaking class
or anything like that
um basically uh kind of jumped into the
deep end
and you know they and what happened was
years and years ago
um i had you know i i did an interview
where they stuck a camera in my face and
they wanted to record some
some some things for for a pilot for a
tv show
and it was awful i was terrible uh i you
know i
i it turns out i'm not good at
memorizing lines i didn't understand how
to talk to the camera
there's a lot going on there when you
see somebody who's very smooth on camera
that's very rarely uh their first time
in front of a camera and just like
anything else you know like learning
about
type 2 super conductivity this is not
necessarily something comes natural you
have to do it a few times and
see how you're bad at it and go oh
next time i'll do this uh and
so you uh you evolve hate use that word
uh but you you change you learn you you
uh fix things that go wrong and at some
point you get better
uh and i you know it's it's an ongoing
process i see
again friends of mine on camera and i
think wow i will never be that smooth
in one take uh so it's always going to
happen there's always going to be
people out there who do it better but
that doesn't mean you can't improve
and if that means you know you can take
classes now
on science outreach that did not exist
when i would
one reason i never did this formally is
because i couldn't you can get degrees
in this sort of thing now
right uh that wasn't true 20 30 years
ago
uh and and so you know god bless them
the folks coming in now and doing it
they're gonna be a whole lot better than
my generation
yeah well yeah and i i think about it by
the way you're getting a request from
from christian ready who is the
proprietor of the launch pad astronomy
uh youtube channel which uh he has been
so gracious to have me on
he wants me to plug in my spare time
you to come on his broadcast planetarium
broadcast so i'll
i'll work email yeah okay i will
have him email great um so the next uh
topics i want to turn to now after we've
kind of gone
through the uh science communication
gamut is what fascinates you so much
about science and
uh what kinds of things would you be
doing i'm going to give you
we're going to do a thought experiment
i'm going to give you three different
budgets
ranging from a million to 10 million
to a billion dollars and i'm going to
ask you what you would do with those
budgets what interests you about science
and
and what do you make of the kind of very
high you know level
of commitment funding wise talent wise
this this kind of
spectrum of people around the world that
we need and get to work with
to make scientific discoveries possible
so what
uh excites you the most about astronomy
these days
or physics or science in general what
are you most fascinated in what
questions are the most burning to you
right now
uh that's that's interesting i don't
know if anybody's asked me that in quite
that way
um a lot of it a lot of what's going on
right now is really fascinating and and
some of it
is not necessarily the sort of
groundbreaking work
um that you expect like you know we're
learning about
what the universe was like in its first
few seconds or you know how black holes
work
some of it is just uh you know we're
we're
we're finding new planets orbiting other
stars i love exoplanets this whole field
is just amazing to me
that when i was a kid we did not know of
any planets orbiting other stars
uh in 1992 they found the first ones and
then in 1995 they started finding them
orbiting stars kind of like the sun
and and now i haven't even i don't even
know where we are now it's well past
four
thousand uh confirmed planets orbiting
other stars
um and that that has all been very
exciting i mean it's really exciting to
think yes we are now seeing that
our solar system isn't special we didn't
really know right and
when i was a kid and you'd read these
theories about the hypotheses of how
the planets formed and they were always
sort of these wacky ideas
and it's like that doesn't seem like you
know a nearby star passing the sun
pulls off a tendril of gas and this
collapses to form planets
it's like well that doesn't happen very
often if that's the case
then we may be the only planetary system
in the galaxy and it turns out
that idea is totally wrong um but the
idea
the the bigger idea here is that you
know are we
special in some way or not and it turns
out no it looks like
uh a large fraction if not most stars
have planetary systems around them or or
did and they're they're changing all the
time and so there's a lot of
a lot of a lot of stuff on the on the
edge there on the forefront of science
where we're learning about
planetary atmospheres how planets behave
how they form
and a lot of it is just i don't want to
say stamp collecting because
that's sort of a denigrating term but a
lot of it is simply just
there's another planet there's another
planet there's another planet and and
you accumulate this
knowledge you accumulate this and at
some point it's
you're not just looking at each one as
being special you're starting to look at
each one of them is belonging to a group
and as the numbers get bigger and bigger
you start to see oh we're discovering
more planets like this and fewer like
that
and that sort of thing that sort of
meta-analysis of of not just that we're
discovering them but how
how they're behaving then that's the
next step in science
um that to me is fascinating and i don't
know why i love it
um you know why do you love the music
you love why do you like this genre of
literature and not that genre
it just speaks to you for some reason
for me it's always just been a love of
science uh and uh that's i
i it's hard to disentangle my love of
science and science fiction for that
matter
you know they say did the science
fiction inspire your love of science or
did you love science and that naturally
led you to science fiction
it's both you know it can be both and
they feed on each other yeah and i think
it's the same sort of thing here i just
love it i you know i i don't
it's certainly certainly i enjoy the
large philosophical aspects of it why
are we here
you know is there a purpose and there
are things like there are things that
signs can answer
uh some of those questions and that to
me is fascinating
but you know it's also it's just it's
just a thing i really love
and i and sometimes i think that's
enough
i'm going to take this time to do a
couple of sound effects and get my
money's worth out of this machine
[Music]
horn or two we just love everything
you're doing uh
i'm gonna take a little pause now one of
the benefits of doing what i do
is the money no uh not the money no but
i get to meet incredible people from
around the world including one miguel
tully who lives in colorado not far from
boulder
uh uh and denver and he as a u.s army
veteran
and a a wonderful artist who's gotten
into nfts and he's
he's doing all sorts of blockchain art
for me and for people like upcoming
guests
eric weinstein stay tuned for that i'm
going to play a little interlude because
we're gonna take a little break
pause have a little sip of whatever
you're drinking i've got some
simon's observatory whiskey here that i
would be drinking if it wasn't
passover uh which forbids me from
breaking
the uh the distilled glutinous beverage
known as scotch whiskey but i will take
a little break
we'll come back in about 10 seconds
there we go
now and just enjoy miguel tully's
interlude entitled
yeti ears
and we are back live on the into the
impossible podcast it's a pleasure to be
joined
by none other than dr phil plate the bad
astronomer
followed him for 20 years i think it's
the 20th anniversary of the
release of this book that i have
multiple versions and copies of
that's right bad astronomy written by a
good person
the moon landing hoax astrology misuses
and misconceptions revealed
and now i want to turn to a delicate
subject and i'm hoping to get your
advice because you uh do so much
uh you know outreach and connection to
the world uh
i often get emails and the emails will
start off uh professor keating with a
lot of lavish praise
we love what yeah i love what you do and
it's wonderful and there's just one
problem with your guest frank wilcek
and sheldon glashau and barry barish
they don't really know the secret of the
theory of everything that i've
discovered
and that i need access to you because
i'm not good at math
but if you help me i do promise you
that i will share the nobel prize uh
that
uh that i will surely win i will share
at least the money uh maybe maybe not
the money i'll share the medal you can
borrow it on weekends
uh so i get this a lot where there are
people you know kind of saying einstein
was wrong
they thought einstein was right but he's
actually kind of a little bit of a crank
and
and he got made all those blunders right
so scientists make blunders
i make blunders therefore i'm like
einstein uh but the question i have for
you is
the other side of things i get also very
serious scientists uh your friend
michio kaku is coming on the show next
week and he has a book called uh the god
equation
and i'll get to god a little bit later
if you'll indulge me uh but the god
equation speaks about knowing the mind
of god if we only can come up with a one
inch long
equation that will unite uh physics and
uh all the physics of the atom with the
physics of the of the cosmos
and uh i sometimes wonder are they
cranks too
you know and and how do we how do you
you know put together a crank detector i
mean this is an obviously erudite person
incredibly brilliant he was one of the
forefathers and is offstring theory and
i
wish him a great deal of success but you
know when you make claims like that
uh you know that it's that it's somehow
um you know so far out and people
thought i was crazy or they thought
someone was crying how do i deal with
that i guess i'm begging you
how do i deal with the kind of uh you
know how do i walk the line
when someone could be a genius could
have the true theory of everything later
hopefully today i'm talking with eric
weinstein about his theory called
geometric unity
how do you know that somebody or it's
worth pursuing because
we only have so much time it's a very
limited resource so what would you
advise
well you can't know right um you can
know when someone's wrong
uh i get a lot of well i i don't get as
many emails as you might expect for
somebody who stuck his neck out
to debunk uh bad ideas uh it's
kind of amazing my friends my my friends
who do more science than i do uh tend to
get more
i'll send you something but yeah thanks
uh that's okay
um but you know i can get an email and
know right away this
this person's wrong if first of all if
they just say einstein was wrong
i'm done delete or you know on twitter i
was wrong he made a blunder right
but he well yeah sure he made he made a
mistake
um but that was just in us you know
we're talking about here i assume you're
talking about the cosmological constant
where uh in his equations that when
einstein wrote out his equations of the
the behavior of the universe um uh it
was thought that the universe was static
at the time it wasn't it wasn't changing
really
but his equations implied that it was
either expanding or contracting
and he just said well that that
obviously can't be so he threw an extra
thing into his equation
which made it static uh and it turns out
that was a mistake
but it was a mistake made for the right
reason and it turns out his equations
were in fact correct and the universe is
expanding
uh and so even if you want to say that
he was wrong about some things
um he wasn't wrong about everything
relativity
works super well you know if you drove
around uh
using well nothing not that many people
are driving at the moment but if
if you're using uh uh gps uh
for your map system in your car or
whatever that won't work without
relativity
um everything everything we see is not
working now relativity
excuse me everything we see in in
astronomy pretty much
is is very well defined by relativity um
but not not exactly everything i don't
want to over
exaggerate that quantum mechanics which
talks about the very small and
relativity which talks about the very
large things that are moving very fast
things have a lot of gravity
those two theories don't talk to each
other well when they overlap and that's
a that's a real problem right now
um that's that's hawking radiation out
of black holes and all these sort of
things
is sort of where that those two uh
theories have their frontier with each
other
um and so yeah you know it doesn't
explain everything doesn't mean it's
wrong
like people say newton was wrong
einstein showed newton's wrongs like no
he didn't
he improved what newton had come up with
newton just was incomplete
einstein added to that and so we're
going to have another theory that will
add to
relativity at some point because we know
relativity is incomplete
and so is quantum mechanics um the thing
is
if somebody says i've been able to do
that you know i um
who needs a college education and math
and i'm like well
you kind of have to understand the math
to to show
how quantum mechanics and relativity
work you have to understand how they
work first before you can show how
they're wrong
and if somebody just jumps right in with
an email to me and says einstein was
wrong
um yeah we're done yeah but if somebody
says to me einstein was incomplete and
i've got this idea
typically it's you know it's it's going
to be over my head i'm not
a cosmologist i'm not a relativistic
physicist i don't know that stuff to
that level
um so it's some it's if it seems right i
i'll email them back and say
this is interesting but you know i can't
help you you need to talk to somebody
else
um and if it's if it's clearly a
crackpot uh away it goes
how do you tell the difference i don't
know you kind of know it when you see
that helping out here phil well it's
like everything else
in the universe there's it's not binary
it's not crackpot and right
right there there's a spectrum along
this along this this continuum here
and you you just have to decide at what
point it gets too fuzzy for you to be
able to say
one way or another and we see this over
and over again in astronomy we see it in
human behavior
we see it in in everything um
and i don't you know it and scientists
do this too i
you know i've i've known scientists who
later in life typically
have kind of lost it they've lost their
their way and they're making these grand
assumptions that are wrong
uh or or at least not based on
a good evidence and i can't say anything
about mitchuk's book i haven't read it
um i haven't read avi loeb's book about
uh
omua um i've just seen what he's written
you know online and stuff like that and
i can say
i think saying it's a spaceship is going
too far um
if if somebody comes out with a book
that says you know we are
approaching an equation which describes
god
and they'd be like well you know let's
define our terms here what do you mean
by god
uh and and if you mean you have an
equation which unites quantum mechanics
and relativity
and and can when when examined correctly
can explain every known phenomenon in
the universe
uh yeah let's talk about that but if you
want to jump into
a religious aspect of this i kind of
back off and go well
i'm not so sure yeah i always say you
know a theory of everything is sometimes
not as good as
or not as bad as a theory of anything
and oftentimes i have to
i'm trying to call it up here but um the
end of kaku's book and again
i have great respect for him i always
treat my guests with uh you know
fairness and and and conciliation or
conciliatory approach
uh because i do think you know debates
are rarely won right i mean you're
really like oh man you made a great
point now i'm gonna vote for trump you
know i mean this is not gonna happen
right i i don't think i could convince
you of that in anything that was me
no yeah but uh but looking at uh looking
at
you know religion and you know i think i
had on as i said an intelligent design
proponent and that was a lot of fun and
we were respectful uh however i do feel
like the god card is overplayed a lot in
science by people that are secular for
example
the last few words of um kaku's book
this time
uh the god equation are the last three
words from
uh stephen hawking's apocal a brief
history of time which i'm sure you read
and i read and influenced me greatly
and those words are you know when we can
come up with this equation or this
theory
then we will truly know the mind of god
and
we've heard about god particles we've
heard about you know the mind of god the
god equation
um so i just feel like it is kind of
banded about and
and i i don't think that does a lot of
service either to god because i think a
lot of times even from a theological
standpoint
you know people that you know are are so
distant from it they
they might be looking for the authority
that religion connotes
or in in bantam's case in the case of
stephen hawking's first publisher and
brief history
the editor supposedly put his you know
foot down said you have to
you can't rule out you know god you know
half of our of our audience is going to
be cut out and the other half will be
cut out
by the equation that you had in the book
you know he famously said every equation
reduces your audience by half
and every mention of god doubles it so
uh i now want to turn to you know kind
of science and
and and um and humanity uh but more on
the political standpoint
not not your politics but just how do
you do what do you how do you handle
things that
have a scientific impact on human
affairs
where you know it's almost as if the
scientists play a role
in the governance of human beings and oh
yeah absolutely
we like to see nowadays that the
budget's increasing with the current
administration that's all wonderful
um but then you hear other things like
we're the party of science
and we believe in science or follow the
science and i'm afraid that sometimes
it might mean like obey scientists and i
feel like no i voted for the president i
didn't vote for like
some unnamed you know phalanx of
unaccountable dictator scientist right
so uh the question specifically in the
in the chat room is about starlink
you know which will provide internet low
cost cover the whole planet perhaps and
and bring bandwidth as joe biden our
president
just mentioned a couple days that's a
huge priority to bring internet
to underserved populations on the other
hand that might impact science right it
might
destroy certain astronomical
measurements specifically in causing
microarray background research where the
signals are
in our band uh so to speak but also an
optical astronomy so what do you make of
that the
the kind of unelected nature of science
and the fact that we're asked to listen
to scientists
sorry for rambling but how do you
balance the the
listening to science three different
things yeah i mean any one of these
three topics could be like an
hour-long discussion um we're halfway
done
we're almost wrapping up so i promise i
won't be under anymore
when a politician on behalf of their
party says we are the party of science
uh uh yeah put make sure your your hands
on your wallet in your back pocket and
not gonna get stolen um in in this
particular case
uh you know politicians can say things
like that and i know in
in fact there are politicians who have
been saying we are the party of science
now and
and the evidence is not there for that
in fact the evidence is quite strongly
against them
um here's the thing our
society depends on science right now um
you know
engineering uh if you wanna you wanna
put science and engineering in the same
blunt when i and i'm i'm okay with that
in this case
uh but we depend on this uh critically
for our civilization we are talking over
the internet right now i'm talking you
through a camera
which uses uh quantum mechanics
and uh electrical equations and
relativity because of the satellites
there's just all of the science that
goes into the internet and our economy
is
strongly dependent on the internet um
the science is showing us that fossil
fuels
are making our planet uninhabitable uh
in in some senses
uh that is science that is a scientific
conclusion
and that sort of science you know if if
i discover that spiral arms in a galaxy
wind one way
versus another that's probably not going
to affect how
you're going to buy food next week on
the other hand if uh
if if somebody has a bogus science uh
research thing that says if we if we
damn this river it's just going to be
money flowing into your bank you know
that's
you got to be careful here there is
science that absolutely
impacts you directly in your daily life
and uh you know if if in in 20 years
you're probably not going to be able to
find
a gasoline-powered car to buy maybe not
20 years but in some time in the near
future
that's a scientific decision that is
influencing politics when the
politicians say
yeah you know what we're going to ban
cfcs because they're destroying the
ozone
we're going to ban you know we're going
to make sure we're going to test for
mercury in your water
these are scientific findings that you
that have to be applied
to our lives science is going to be
political
in this sense uh it's not always obvious
what the choice is
uh we saw this with the vaccinations
over the past year when they
you know how and just with covet itself
how is it spread
is it spread by touching is it spread by
aerosols is it you know this that
should we wear a mask one mess two
master would be indoors outdoors
the science wasn't obvious at first and
that caused some confusion
now we have a lot better grasp of that
thing so you've got to also realize that
you can't just take the first science
comes along and apply it
we have to learn what's going on there
can be subtle effects that we don't
understand
people don't like to think that way and
that makes it harder um
but you know you're not electing
shadowy dictatorial scientists you know
these scientists are out there doing
their thing
they have to talk they are beholden in
in their position to talk to politicians
politicians are beholden to listen to
the scientists
not pick and choose the science they
like and don't like which is what
the party of science is doing right now
um but to listen to them and say
you know how how sure we have this and
what kind of policy can we put into
place now
uh that is best given what we understand
right now
that i think is the role of science and
politics and politics and science
right and yeah you have to be careful
you don't end up like galileo and get
you know fact check false by the uh
prevailing scientific authorities of the
day
you know he also irritated the the uh
authorities at the time too he went out
of his way to do that so yeah that's a
good lesson for scientists too that's
right not one i think i i seem to have
taken terribly well i pick on
politicians all the time
yeah and it's not like he didn't have an
example bruno was only you know
10 years older than him and he uh he
suffered as well for
being slightly impolitic as they say so
yes i won't be saying anything negative
about uh about the director of the
national science foundation today
um so i'm just showing on the screen
here the the um
the triumph of human reason if we find
an answer to that hawking says
it will be the ultimate triumph of human
reason for then
we would know the mind of god
well we've been uh privileged to be
picking the mind of phil plate
bad astronomer good person fun to talk
to and phil i'm gonna wrap up the stream
as i do
with all the guests who honor me with
their presence here uh we have a
tremendous
fan base here for you and i do want to
encourage people to go to
uh phil's phil's twitter handle which is
at
badastronomer and uh and give him a
follow he
is worth following and he has a
wonderful newsletter about astronomy
news
which comes out every monday i read it
religiously
and uh even will sometimes not read the
full
edition the print edition of physical
review d so i can just
concentrate on phil's newsletter uh phil
what i do typically is i ask i'm not
peer reviewed though
not yet that's right that that's uh when
you pay for the the version on substance
then you get the peer review that's
right yeah
uh so i ask all my guests the following
uh
three questions one is going to take us
into your personal future
uh 60 70 years from now when you depart
this mortal coil of natural causes in
your sleep
uh like my grandfather not like those
people in the backseat of his car
no no i'm just kidding that didn't
happen but uh it revolves around what is
known as an
ethical will and it's partially related
to the nobel prize
in that alfred nobel didn't have
children it didn't have heirs
biological at least and he endowed this
prize to
partake in activities that would lead to
the benefit of all mankind
so it wasn't purely about material or
technology it was about benefiting human
life
i want to ask you what would you put in
your will
that revolves around wisdom so we call
it a wisdom will azava ah
in hebrew it means basically an ethical
will what kind of thing would you want
for future generations to know
specifically about you
um that i had a
joy about science
and and in this case i mean science as a
method
of understanding reality as best we can
and
uh that it there is joy in it and
there's passion in it
uh and that if when you when you truly
start to understand
the way the universe works it becomes
a thing of beauty a thing of art and
that art and science are simply two
sides of the same coin
wow that's lovely and it fits in very
nicely with
uh sir arthur c clarke who is the
namesake of this
institution that i co-direct for human
imagination uc san diego
and we'll get to the the final question
relating to the name of the podcast in
just one bit
uh the second question now takes us not
to your far future
you know as uh woody allen said um you
know i
what do you want people to say about you
in 100 years he said i want to say
i want them to say that i look pretty
good for 180 year old
but i want to ask you in a billion years
uh what kind of
sentence would most encapsulate what
humans have learned about science as of
2021 and i'll
i'll give you a lead uh elite in what
how richard feynman passed guest
on my podcast no no he wasn't a guest on
my podcast and he was
actually famous for saying uh the first
principle is that you shouldn't fool
yourself
and the second principle is today's
april fool's day but uh hopefully i
haven't been too foolish but getting
back to feynman he said the most
important statement that contains the
most information and fewest words
is that everything is made of atoms i
want to ask you what
discovery about science or you know in
one sentence or two maybe
would you put on a monolith like these
monoliths that appear in 2001 a space
odyssey
uh that would last for a billion years
is there anything that encapsulates
how much how grand humans have achieved
the grandeur of our achievement
that in scientific terms that you would
feel is worthy of
betray you know portraying on a time
capsule to last for billions of years
perhaps
that is a tough question that's an
interesting one um
i i might quote somebody else
and say that um life is the universe's
way of knowing itself
that the universe without life is just a
thing that exists but when life
can actually comprehend what the
universe is and life's
part of that universe you know that's
that's when things get very interesting
so
i would say probably uh the universe
doesn't revolve around you
uh humans humans finally maybe started
to figure this out we took our first
steps towards figuring that out
that we were part of a much larger
reality um that we had
that we had ever known before uh and
that
we strove to seek out
how that how the universe works and and
what our
part in it is wow uh so i have a
question from
creon levitt who's joining us on
clubhouse
and uh creon can you hear me
i sure can thanks for bringing me up of
course great conversation
um yeah i i guess i wanted to know
um if you came up with that yourself
about the universe
and about life being how the universe uh
becomes aware of itself or if you
are aware of john wheeler's many uh
statements and aphorisms in that
direction the great physicist john
wheeler
oh yeah i mean i like i said uh uh i'll
quote somebody else here i i wasn't sure
who said it i've seen it so many times
in some different ways
but it's such a wonderfully beautiful
and fundamental thought uh uh
that without life the universe is just
you know it has no way of studying
itself
but but life yeah you know i
i don't like when people say what's the
meaning of life and i think well there's
no meaning
to life it's not like there's a law
written down that says here's what you
have to do
it's it's it's more like what you know
what meaning do you find
being alive what meaning do you find in
the universe
uh those are it's just it's a subtle
difference um but i like it and i like
the idea that without life the universe
just exists but with life it's you know
when we study the universe we are
studying ourselves and vice versa
and carl sagan has said
oh go ahead that's something that sam
paris certainly has brought up many
times which is
um it's kind of like without conscious
without what you mean really is
consciousness because life i mean
i don't think that slime molds are busy
studying the universe
but maybe they are but anyway um i think
we're
maybe conflating consciousness with life
here but here's the issue
like a universe without life presumably
although
not assuredly is without consciousness
and then the issue is well
the universe without consciousness is
like an utter failure like there's
nobody home
the lights aren't on there's no there's
no joy there's no love there's no
suffering
it's dead and um so
it's very interesting to consider
not it's very interesting consider the
implications of that and particularly as
you might know
it's extremely interesting considering
the implications of that
that if the earth isn't the only
place within our bubble radius
that harbors consciousness right because
that puts a lot
of burden and promise on our shoulders
whereas if
you're one of these typical scientists
who i worked with for so many years at
nasa not universally but typically who
are like oh
for sure life is everywhere in the
cosmos and there's consciousness and
technology
you know hundreds and thousands of
planets it's like yeah well in that case
it doesn't really matter what happens to
us and that's a great way to get them
segalistic and nihilistic because humans
don't matter who they care who cares
someone else will carry the torch we
don't know that we might be alone
we should behave as if we are because if
we are alone
the entire future of the universe hinges
on us okay great thank you crayon we've
got one more
uh time for one more comment from martin
uh ham
how are you i'm doing good thanks
um so i have one question um actually
two
one is politics so do you think that
ubi could help realize the totality
of human creative force and if politics
doesn't work uh what is your favorite
sci-fi book
and movie okay thank you very much
i the first part was garbled what was
the first part of the course he's asking
about
uh universal basic income which i do
think uh makes an appearance in many
different
clubs yes in many different sci-fi
scenarios in one form or another so
first about that
uh and then um and if you have time
as second question as well yeah a lot of
time for the second question because i
can't answer the first one um
uh i i'm not an economist uh and so i i
have no idea
if that's the right way to go or not i
like the idea of raising the minimum
wage
to to keep up with inflation so that
people who are doing
important jobs are are paid for i think
everybody who works
should it be be recompensed at a rate
where they can afford to live
uh and so that that that to me makes
makes sense i don't i don't even
understand why we're not paying people
enough
uh when we have the money to do this um
so
that aside um i don't have a favorite
science fiction book or movie um because
it it's it's a uh you know everything's
neck and neck and it's like what did i
read last i mean
i i was talking about the expanse
earlier and that's that's probably my
favorite science fiction tv show that's
on right now
i love it i also love star trek um i
like the expanse
books i've got i've read all the books
up to the last one which is coming out
soon
um when i was a kid you know i loved
larry niven and arthur c
clarke um i've actually got somewhere oh
look at this
i've got uh the coming of the space age
no way the first edition
by far arthur c clarke and um uh it's
even got his uh
his book his wow oh shoot it's falling
out
his book it is book plate holy cow and
he signed it
this was given to me wow yeah this was
given to me by somebody who knew him
many years ago
i never met him um but you know and it
just
and it's it's like anything it's do you
have a favorite piece of music and it's
like well it depends you know if i'm
happy i want to listen to this if i'm
sad i want to listen to this
so i i i try to avoid uh those kind of
superlatives if i can
got it i'm not trying to be weasely no
i'm actually trying to be a little bit
more uh more subtle and allow a little
more uh complexity into the question
god forbid you ever weasel out of
anything and those aren't allowed in
colombia
yeah you're live near a weasel farm out
there in colorado
uh we're joined also today by john
michael gautier of the
event horizon uh youtube channel please
everybody subscribe to that
i have uh some rumors that i will be on
that channel very shortly the event
horizon channel i've been on it before
and it's one of my favorite
of all time as well as launch pad
astronomy uh run by christian reddy
these are just some of the brightest
and best channels and audience in the
known multiverse
but for now i want to conclude because i
know your time is so valuable
uh uh with uh with everything you're
involved with phil plate the bad
astronomer i'm gonna ask you one last
piece of advice
in this case it revolves around the
namesake arthur c clarke of this
podcast who said once the only way of
discovering the limits of the possible
is to venture a little way past them
into the impossible
and that's the name of the podcast
that's how i came up with that i want to
ask you advice to your former self
what aspect of life of science of
the universe once mystified you but
eventually
you found the courage to go into the
impossible and became
that much richer for doing so
ah wow that's such an interesting
question because i'm not sure i ever
have right
i was never like i said i wasn't really
this groundbreaking scientist on the
other hand
um it could be like some of the work
well yeah
some of the work we did on hubble was
looking at things that nobody had ever
been able to see before in such clarity
discs of gas and dust forming planets
around
stars and again you know when i was a
kid we didn't know if there were other
planets out there so
scientifically i would say basically
you know kid don't worry a lot of the
questions you have right now
they're gonna they're gonna work out
you're gonna figure this out uh and
you're gonna work with people who know
who know the stuff even better and
you'll learn from them
um if i if i had life advice to myself
as a kid
um it would erase my reality now quite
substantially because i was
i've talked about this in other other
interviews before but i was
a very privileged kid right in the in
the in the
social sense of privilege these days
very isolated in my thinking not
uh didn't really understand how other
people thought uh
and wound up growing out of that in a
series of um rapid
uh uh uh sort of knee to the stomach
sort of oof
events where you know where you get very
embarrassed and you have to think back
it's like oh gosh i've been a jerk this
whole time
um you share one one of those fellas
are they just you know attitudes about
about everything about again about
about other people it prejudices um uh
misogyny all of that sort of thing when
you grow up in that environment
and you don't think about it and then
you get out of that environment all of a
sudden you realize
wow i really was in a bubble and i got a
lot of learning to do
um and that that for some people that
happens over their whole life sometimes
it happens as an epiphany
um for me it was a series of small
embarrassing epiphanies
uh and i and i'm still trying so what i
think in that case i would say
to this kid you know you're living your
life a certain way and seeing things a
certain way
there are other ways of seeing this you
have to venture outside of what you
think
is the only way things go and that's
going to seem hard and it may seem
impossible
to use that word um but you know event
if you
if you do this on your own you will
avoid a lot of a lot of embarrassing
situations later
uh so that i think that would be my
advice i think and
am i still here yeah am i so yeah yeah
it didn't work
oh well as you go did you actually
teleport back great reference there and
i think it's all the more appropriate uh
although i am uh devoutly jewish
uh it is easter weekend and we do uh
want to recognize the
ability for human beings to achieve
redemption i think that is one of the
good aspects of religion that we don't
treat people
uh there's so much cancellation and so
forth and and just as you say you should
be able to forgive yourself
phil because you've done tremendous good
for the planet for the universe
uh we look up to you and uh and you've
given a tremendous amount and there's
the company in this audience now has
even expanded even further than i
thought it would now we got fraser kane
in the in the crowd
uh who is uh another hero of mine a
friend of the show
a delight in all ways and i just want to
thank you uh
for coming on the show i want to
encourage my whole audience please
please please
visit all the great stuff that phil does
you can find it
bad astronomers sci-fi we didn't get a
chance to talk about sci-fi i do want to
talk about that someday
all the cool stuff i write a lot you can
find it and yeah you'll find it in the
bad astronomy newsletter you gotta
subscribe to that get the paid version
give them a give them a little bit of
feedback monetarily
which we've only been doing since the
late phoenician period on earth uh
subscribe to his newsletter subscribe to
this channel we have neil degrasse tyson
coming next week
we have michiokaku coming next week i'm
gonna have to space these guys out
uh john mather sarah seeger we have
unbelievable guests coming up on the
into the impossible podcast
and i just want to extend a special
thanks to you phil uh for for really you
know
going out there a long time ago taking a
risk going into the impossible
writing a wonderful book continuing as a
scientist in the public eye
the public looks to you you have a huge
platform i
i just uh i i can't thank you enough for
the way that you use it so i want to
wish everyone
blessings if you do celebrate the
holiday season of easter
enjoy that otherwise my semitic friends
enjoy the rest of passover
and we will have you and see you next
time with great guests we may even get a
visit from eric weinstein
later today it is april fools and he did
promise a special release so stay tuned
subscribe like do all those cool things
and subscribe to everybody
that you can in the chat room as well
for now signing off and thanking phil
from the bottom of our hearts for
joining us on the into the impossible
podcast and we'll take us out
with again another beautiful musical
interlude from one of my greatest
friends
on the channel who i wouldn't have met
if i didn't do this podcast miguel tully
us army veteran and colorado inhabitant
yeti tears as his name so for now
signing off have a wonderful rest of
your day thank you phil
thank you